oh
l'année tonique de la résistance
l'indépendance dit elle ne sera pas
remise en cause par les menaces de
moscou encore de nouvelles mesures pour
l'intégration des artistes invités
l'homme qui y croient maurice benassaya
rugby montferrand agen et le racing
qualifier les parisiens ont frôlé
l'élimination
portrait d'une star denise gence molière
90 de la meilleure actrice joue le chant
du départ à nice bonsoir mais tout
d'abord l'image du jour l'image symbole
de ce dimanche 6 mai impossible de
monter sur les planches aujourd'hui à
deauville
un monde fou sur les routes de normandie
reportage de jacques lacan disait que
les tropiques nbc
ne boudons pas notre plaisir
la mère et la suprême récompense de ces
minutes écoulées à patienter juste le
temps de garer sa voiture
non l'exemple n'est peut-être pas
excellent me lire et où cela ne fait
rien la conquête du graal touche à sa
fin la mère est là enfin presque là
faudrait au bout il ya tellement de
monde j'ai jamais vu ça
la mer vous voulez la voir la voilà il
suffit d'être patient dans la vie et
puis ensuite rien ne sert de se
précipiter pour bronzer un peu de marche
ça fait toujours du bien
rien de comparable avec les piétinements
sur les champs elysées où le boulevard
haussmann à propos de champs elysées ici
et pas beaucoup de salles de cinéma mais
on en connaît un rayon
loin du cinéma c'est une ville de
festivals il ya même des stars à
deauville ces vedettes toujours les
mêmes les bienfaits de l'air iodé sont
incomparables vive les ponts ce n'est
pas tout 17 heures il va falloir songer
à rentrer reprendre sa voiture
malheureusement avant paris on va
retrouver les bouchons avouez tout de
même que cela
ça gâche un peu le plaisir d'une journée
au bord de la mer l'actualité à
l'étranger michael gorbatchev se fâche
après la lituanie il menace aujourd'hui
la lettonie de mesures de rétorsion si
elle maintient sa proclamation
d'indépendance après avoir souhaité le
dialogue les autorités lettonienne ont
réaffirmé ce matin le caractère
intangible de leurs décisions
reportage à riga de nos envoyés spéciaux
hélène risacher et joseph tual
restons calmes tel est le message des
responsables indépendantistes de
lettonie ce soir le président du
parlement gorbunov c'est une
intervention télévisée
pour expliquer le flou d'indépendance de
la population et une réponse déclaration
télévisée alarmiste hier soir du
secrétaire général du pc de lettonie
affirmant que gorbatchev allait prendre
des sanctions contre la lettonie
je n'ai pas lu le message de mikhaïl
gorbatchev de toute façon je pense qu'il
n'a pas encore eu le temps de lire les
documents que je lui ai envoyé je les
lui ai téléphoné demain matin et il nous
appelons au dialogue de toute façon leur
canton sanctions économiques qu'elles
ont déjà commencé si elles n'ont aucun
rapport avec notre déclaration
d'indépendance
elles sont dues à la crise économique a
riga les habitants en russe et les tons
s'attendent plus ou moins des
représailles de moscou sur ce sujet
évidemment les réactions divergent
je ne peux pas croire qu'il y aura un
blocus économique je suis contre
l'indépendance mais j'espère qu'on
arrivera à un dialogue
nous avons très peur de ce qui va se
passer maintenant moi je suis russe
jusqu'à présent ça allait bien et
maintenant j'ai peur ça va être de pire
en pire je le sais bien
nous savons que gorbatchev à prendre des
mesures contre nous
après la déclaration d'indépendance il
va y avoir des pénuries mais tout le
monde est prêt à supporter moi je ne
sais pas s'il y aura des sanctions mais
quelque chose que tu arrivé parce qu'on
voit des soldats et ce n'est pas très
rassurant supporter quelques années
difficiles
ray ça ira mieux même si rigueur reste
calme depuis quelques jours les troupes
d'élite en tenue de combat arpentent les
rues fermement les ils sont là et chaque
soir depuis le 4 mai proclamation
d'indépendance de la lettonie bourride
canon dans la ville
les soldats répète le défilé d'une femme
est en pleine répétition bouillante tour
native d'impressionner la population en
roumanie
l'ouverture du dialogue et les excuses
publiques du président lyonnais liège
coûts n'ont pas calmé l'ardeur des
contestataires il était encore quinze
mille aujourd'hui sur la place de
l'université à bucarest mais leur
mouvement ne représente pas forcément
les sentiments de la population roumaine
des les faubourgs de bucarest la cote de
popularité du président est lié jusqu où
montent en flèche c'est ce qu'ont
constaté nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe pisteurs et marc d'où le moulin
de bulbes uqat à petit bourg de 2000
habitants à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de bucarest
on vient là d'une dizaine de villages
environnants pour y faire moudre son blé
et son maïs la capitale il paraît bien
loin mais avec la radio la télévision on
se tient au courant
je me joins pas d'accord avec ce qui se
passe dans les pays en ce moment
spécialement à bucarest cette
manifestation depuis des jours des
semaines
les manifestants veulent prendre le
pouvoir illégalement ya même des
tziganes là dans ce village qui chaque
jour vont à la manifestation
ils en reviennent avec 420 qui les paye
ça je ne sais pas pour la plupart des
gens ici le choix est fait ils vont
voter pour le front de salut national
les parties paysans et libéraux parlent
de leur redistribuer les terres
collectives
mais ces villageois préfère continuer de
travailler à la coopérative d'état
d'autant que leurs conditions se sont
améliorées
désormais ils sont la semaine de cinq
jours les retraites ont été augmentés
pourquoi les libéraux et ceux du parti
paysan vous ils se disent historique ne
se sont pas exprimés avant la révolution
c'est le front va libérer esclavage dans
village il ya pourtant un représentant
de l'opposition en campagne depuis
maintenant un peu plus de deux mois
dink la gorgue et aussi gardien dans un
dépôt de machines agricoles
c'est le fraîchement nommé chef de la
section du parti national paysans il est
d'ailleurs très fier de cette double
casquette
grâce à l'exceptionnelle réussite le pnp
ici a fait huit adhésion huit membres
maigres résultats mais il faut dire
qu'il n'est pas seulement dû à
l'hostilité des paysans du village
envers les partis traditionnels dinka
est vraiment un piètre politique parce
que je n'ai jamais été communiste et
parce que je suis le chef du bnp ici à
mon avis c'est monsieur jsk où le
meilleur candidat
bref dinka milite pour le parti national
paysans mais ils votent pour le candidat
du front du salut national en france
cent mille personnes ont participé
aujourd'hui au congrès de la jeunesse
ouvrière chrétienne à la courneuve
congrès dominé par les problèmes là
proche des problèmes d'emploi et de
formation sur place marie claire tiers
et christian de carnelle cent mille
jeunes pour un emploi ont chanté sous la
houlette de monseigneur lustiger venu
pour la célébration leurs revendications
l'arrêt des stages bidon un meilleur
apprentissage un suivi de l'information
un grand rassemblement à l'heure où l'on
parle de désinfection syndicale j'avais
il ya quelques années
je pense effectivement de scorer mon
avis trop politisé et on pense plus à
mon avis il a fait à l'avenir de
l'emploi y est pourtant venu me prendre
une formation parce que la formation et
j'entamerai toujours un petit boulot
galère dans les allées rencontre avec un
ancien de la joc jacques delors se faire
plus pour les jeunes qui sont qui ont
moins de chances qu'ils sont dans un
milieu familial plus faible du point de
vue culturel que l'on fait pour le pour
les honteux non pas simplement se
glorifier de notre système élitiste de
formation que l'on nous envie d'ailleurs
de moins en moins est d'ailleurs le pays
aux systèmes d'information et moins
élitiste open ses résultats économiques
un stage de quoi des plus graves
oui et j'ai trouvé
alors vous allez partie un message
d'espoir pour tous ces jeunes alors que
mercredi en conseil des ministres sera
adopté un projet de loi sur le travail
précaire
et discours il y à quelques minutes de
michel rocard devant ce congrès de la
jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne le premier
ministre s'est placé comme le défenseur
des valeurs de tolérance
je ne laisserai pas la société française
fabriquer des hommes et des femmes qui
auraient perdu l'espoir
je ne laisserai pas les causes les
phénomènes et les discours d'exclusion
prendre le dessus
je ne laisserai pas incité à la haine
entre les peuples
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous pour
combattre toute forme de racisme ou de
xénophobie la solidarité l'intégration
la tolérance je le sais sont au coeur de
votre démarche
l'humanisme aussi au grand rassemblement
national de l'église réformée de france
à enghien la plus importante des églises
protestantes tient son synode jusqu'à
demain ces quelques 150 représentants
laïcs religieux examine les problèmes
posés par la pénurie de pasteur et la
catéchèse la religion protestante et la
troisième heure en france par
l'importance de ses fidèles mais c'est
peut-être aussi la plus discrète exemple
ce matin dans une paroisse du 6e
arrondissement de paris reportage
nathalie darrigrand henry et des
recharges pas tellement ce que ça y'en a
même qui croit presque pour crash sûreté
sur des croix retourner qu'on est les
plus fous que tu nous fais comme ça ils
savent vraiment pas que c'est un culte
chrétien pour eux c'est vraiment pas
bien
la réflexion c'est sourire et pourtant
si le protestantisme et la troisième
religion en france elle est certainement
la plus méconnue car la plus discrète
notre foi tous les jours dans les choses
que nous faisons mais peut-être notre
première but c'est de ne pas se faire
parler de nous mais plutôt de jésus
christ
ici dans ce temple 150 à 200 personnes
viennent tous les dimanches assisté au
culte une paroisse particulièrement
animé on y accueille des étudiants
étrangers
les gens de passage on organise des
voyages bref on privilégie l'ouverture
et on soigne son image vivant il était
un temps où les protestants se méfier de
l'image et privilégier la parole nous
sommes un peuple de la parole de la
bible mais je crois que ce temps est
passé maintenant nous savons que par
l'image il passe aussi dans un message
très important
l'image d'une religion dynamique ce
matin les jeunes de la paroisse
dirigeait le sermon comment vivre sa foi
en 90 comment affirmer sa différence
la foi protestante nous permet de sentir
des liens beaucoup plus étroit j'irai
pas de problème de hiérarchisation
patrol m2 c'est plus une communauté à
l'intérieur de la foi chrétienne
il faut que nous fassions entendre notre
voix et que nous insistions quand on
l'oubli sur le fait que nous nous disons
quelque chose qui est spécifique qui est
peut-être différent de ce que disent les
catholiques se faire entendre voilà bien
le défi lancé aux protestants qui
représente aujourd'hui un peu moins d'1
27 % de la population française
notre dossier ce soir consacré à
l'intégration qui reste difficile des
harkis en france je vous le disais hier
de 60000 en 1962 la communauté musulmane
française est passé à quatre cent mille
personnes aujourd'hui
avant d'évoquer les solutions qui se met
en place avec notre invité maurice
benassaya délégué ministériel chargé des
problèmes des rapatriés
l'exemple d'une rare intégration réussie
celle d'une jeune femme qui a choisi en
plus d'être pilote d'hélicoptère dans
l'armée française reportage à la base
militaire de friedrich a fait non rfa
eric thybaud jean-michel des stands
andrea kenan 24 ans engagé dans l'armée
française depuis trois ans son métier
piloter les hélicoptères de combat anti
char dans un régiment stationnés en
république fédérale d'allemagne l'armée
prendrait à connaît bien son père et
harkis et sous-officiers plus de 3000
militaires harkis ou fils de harkis
vivent en allemagne de l'ouest
mais pour andrea les souvenirs de guerre
de son père en algérie sont très loin je
me sens pas concerné par par ce problème
je suis français je suis de
de religion catholique j'ai vécu en
allemagne
je me considère pas du tout comme tel
souvent c'est que votre fille repartie
encore à la communauté des harkis n'ont
pas les jeunes donc c'est pas je crois
que c'est parce que c'est à 200km de
péniches fun le père d'andrea
participent à une fête organisée à baden
baden par la communauté harkie vivant en
allemagne mais andrea n'a pas voulu
venir
moi même j'y participe enfin moi je le
comprends tout à fait deuxième bombe lui
d'y participer mais y'a pas de raison
qu'on force les enfants y passent
même si c'est une question d'honneur une
question de prestige ou autre c'est donc
aux commandes de sa gazelle of pandaria
passera sa journée ses préoccupations
son métier ses loisirs sa vie privée
bref la vie d'une jeune femme comme les
autres
les difficultés de la communauté harkie
en france andrea ne les connais pas
alors monsieur benassaya exemple réussi
d'intégration par exemple rare oui
pas tout à fait parce que même s'ils
c'est un exemple rare ce n'est pas un
exemple exceptionnel
justement cette fête à laquelle
assistaient que non aux images ont
traduit vers la chaleur il y avait par
exemple colonel tahar où ces psys qui
sort de l'école de l'air le colonel
meliani briançon syrien l'unc l'armée
monsieur benassaya l'armée justement il
serait traité pas seulement la rue et
l'intégration des enfants de harkis ces
armes et france pas seulement l'armée le
premier de normale sup cette année était
un fils de harki djamel ou des choux il
y a dans la presse dans les arts les
lettres le commerce des exemples
d'intégration parfaitement réussi alors
les mesures que nous devons prendre
consiste justement à ce que c'est
ces cas rare de réussite de vienne
davantage de la règle voilà ces mesures
justement est-ce que c'est par exemple
la disparition va le voir sur notre
image des baraquements pardon de le dire
comme ça mais qui ont abrité la
communauté harkie depuis 1962 c'est à
grouiller ici dans le tarn il y en a une
autre par exemple
j'allais dire aussi épouvantable pardon
ajoute au nord de marseille alors qu'est
ce que ça va devenir
est ce qu'il n'ya pas d'avoir un
problème de l'hébergement précisé par
les difficultés de la communauté harkie
ne tient naturellement par si j'ose dire
à la nature de ces populations il faut
savoir qu'en été après 1962 des dizaines
de milliers de harkis ont été entassés
dans de véritables réserves d'indiens
sélectivement les ghettos très
précisément des ghettos à recaler voilà
rien justement nous avons décidé le
gouvernement a décidé de les raser
définitivement mais cela suppose
naturellement avant leur logement que
des mesures de formation adaptés aux
besoins des entreprises soit mené donc
c'est un travail d'assez longue haleine
mais nous sommes décidés à
l'entreprendre les municipalités sont
prêtes à jouer le jeu alors nous
espérons justement mobiliser les élus
locaux
parce que si nous voulons tenter un
habitat diffus pour éviter le ghetto il
faut naturellement que les collectivités
locales prennent leur concours mais
aussi également tous les acteurs
économiques et sociaux afin que les
formations débouchent sur des emplois
pérennisés pardon vous posez la question
ainsi sera ma dernière question c'est
parce que certains harkis c'est bardé de
médailles françaises s'affiche avec jean
marie le pen que vous aviez alors là
aussi il faut faire taire une légende
les harkis les rapatriés français
musulmans sont éloignés de tout
intégrisme à la fois religieux et
politiques
donc il y a pour le moins à l'abus merci
monsieur benassaya les autres faits
marquants de l'actualité en france et à
l'étranger sous forme de télégrammes
commentaires ce soir sophie d'iu
déclaration surprise de tadeus
mazowiecki tout ce soit le premier
ministre polonais accepte de voir les
deux allemands
unifié avant que le soit signé un traité
sur la frontière occidentale polonaise
la fameuse ligne oder nice je souhaite
at-il toutefois je ne fais aboutir à la
signature de ce traité dans les
meilleurs délais qu ils étaient
séquestrés depuis 27 mois car l'ofce la
donne a retrouvé hier soir la liberté
après des semaines d'horreur ce jeune
italien de 20 ans fils d'un riche
industriel avait été enlevé en janvier
88 malgré le paiement d'une rançon
sa famille ne l'avait pas revu les
ravisseurs le relâcher sans doute parce
que la police s'approchait de son lieu
de détention accidents meurtriers en
amérique centrale
un des ses six transportant des
marchandises s'est écrasé dans une
banlieue de guatemala bilan 17 morts
parmi lesquels les trois membres
d'équipage les autres victimes sont des
habitants du quartier sur lequel l'avion
est tombé selon les premiers témoignages
l'appareil a perdu un moteur juste après
le décollage
une enquête est en cours et puis en
france aussi l'avion a tué ce week-end
ce matin les gendarmes ont retrouvé les
débris du petit appareil de tourisme qui
avait disparu guère fait de marmande
le pilote un amateur est mort dans
l'accident qui serait dû à une panne
d'essence hier une collision entre deux
avions de tourisme près de lille avait
également fait une victime
avant d'ouvrir la page strictement
sportives la nouvelle vague de violence
sur les stades en europe des centaines
d'interpellations en belgique en
allemagne aux pays bas et en angleterre
commentaires de laurence bily dernière
journée du championnat en angleterre et
pèse une image de football les hooligans
sont une nouvelle fois frappé à band
pouces 2000 supporters ont attaqué la
police bilan vingt blessés 50
arrestations d'autres violences sur
d'autres stades chesterfield et
birmingham
à un mois du mondial csn inquiéter
autorités britanniques
d'autant que scotland yard a la preuve
que des hooligans sangles et néerlandais
ont tenu des conseils de guerre pour
préparer leur campagne italienne aux
pays bas quelques images de ballons mais
là aussi la rencontre ajax nimègue a été
émaillé par des incidents
déjà la veille un groupe de supporters
d'amsterdam avait provoqué des bagarres
et saccagé un bus le hooliganisme n'a
pas de frontières hier en belgique en
allemagne plusieurs matchs ont été
perturbés pour la coupe du monde en
italie
d'importantes mesures de sécurité seront
prises mais seront elles suffisantes
pour éviter les débordements de
hooligans pas de violence ont
heureusement aujourd'hui dans les rues
de paris ou douze mille personnes ont
participé au 15e marathon de paris
marathon enlevez vous allez le voir sur
ces images par le britannique steve
bresse en deux heures 13 minutes et 10
secondes
il a distancé dans les derniers
kilomètres le français jean-baptiste
protect il prend la deuxième place
l'un des favoris de portugais manuel
mathias s'est classé troisième l'image
donc de bresse victorieux 2 heures 30
minutes et 10 secondes deuxième victoire
consécutive le rugby maintenant avec les
quarts de finale du championnat de
france cet après midi victoire étriquée
d'agen sur toulon beaucoup plus large de
montferrand sur dax et enfin arrachée en
prolongation du racing sur grenoble les
essais du jour commenté par à nador dans
le showbiz du racing n'a pas fait dans
la dentelle face à grenoble mené 15 6 et
encaissant un essai par géra si les
parisiens ont opéré un retour miraculeux
dans les arrêts de jeu cabane le perce
muraille transmet à pouilloux qui au
terme d'un crochet intérieur marque en
moyenne position
l'ape ont réussi sans la transformation
expédition équipe aux travaux forcés les
prolongations cabane l'homme
providentiel du racing voley pour ces
trois cartes
mnl aplatit au pied des poteaux et c'est
synonyme de qualification pour le racing
qui l'emportent 27-21 se lancer melville
en rouge et noir échoue à quelques
centimètres de la ligne d'essai agenaise
image symbolique de ce quart de finale
agen toulon est symptomatique du travail
de sape toulonnais qui sera détruit par
des un jeune est remarquablement bien
organisés en défense
à ce travail d'usure ce sont les agenais
excellent manoeuvrier mieux inspiré qui
se sont montrés intraitables de pénalité
convertie par l'ouvreur pierre montlaur
concrétise au tableau d'affichage leur
supériorité des agenais en deuxième mi
temps le score final 6 0 en faveur
d'agen reflète la différence de niveau
de jeu infinitésimale entre les deux
équipes montferrand c'est l'équipe que
l'on n'attend pas et qui surprend après
avoir arraché in extremis la
qualification devant bègles c'est au
tour des dacquois en rouge de faire les
frais du rugby complet des auvergnats
saint-andré ruto sous vos yeux
inscriront deux des quatre essais
montferrandais qui s'imposent 34 à 12
toulouse sera opposé au racing remake de
la demi-finale de 87 qui avait vu la
victoire des parisiens et agen devrait
se qualifier aux dépens de montferrand
pronostics placé sous la seule
responsabilité d'alain dorgans
gymnastique
vous avez peut-être suivi cet après midi
sur l'a3 les championnats d'europe
féminins qui viennent tout juste de se
terminer à athènes domination
incontestée de la soviétique l'état n'a
bobinska ya elle va prendre sa retraite
à l'âge de 17 ans commentaire de daniel
lauclair des attitudes de stars le
regard déterminé le visage poupon une
silhouette très féminine csv tana
bobinska hier depuis deux ans cette
jeune soviétique originaire de minsk est
la reine des arabesques championne
olympique à séoul par équipes et au saut
de cheval
championne du monde à stuttgart en 89 et
déjà la meilleure européenne l'an passé
à bruxelles devaient tana bobinska ya a
confirmé à athènes qu'elle était sans
rival cinq médailles d'or sur 5
possibles
à la gymnastique dès l'âge de 6 ans je
vais te la nabo guînes sky a aujourd'hui
17 ans elle est au sommet de son art
mais elle parle déjà de prendre sa
retraite en juillet prochain avec des
ambitions plus modestes
la française karine mermet a terminé 5e
au saut mais il faut dire que le cheval
c'est son hub théâtre maintenant denise
gence molière 90 de la meilleure actrice
joue depuis hier soir à nice le chant du
départ de ivan daoudi la comédienne qui
joue une comtesse aux côtés d'hélène
vincent et de jacques weber
portrait d'une star dominique poncet a
retenu dans la vie elle n'est que
modestie discrétion et pudeur les aussi
rire gourmandise et malice sur un
plateau elle est de cette race de
comédienne qui non seulement font
étinceler les textes mais qui en plus
obligent leurs partenaires à offrir le
meilleur d'eux mêmes car elle n'est
qu'exige ans et générosité
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était un art
collectif avec tout ce que ça veut dire
à la fois l'auteur et metteur en scène
les partenaires donc c'est ça je suis
pas sanitaires et puis en plus en nous
ne sommes nous comédiens que des
intermédiaires
alors quand la nature est une espèce de
persévérance vous permet de durer en
tant qu'intermédiaire moi quand j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en parler je voudrais avant
tout avoir l'air reconnaissante parce
que je suis vraiment reconnaissant
encore deux heures l'enfer attend votre
héritier c'est une telle chance vous
voir prendre la parole avec des gens qui
écrivent des mots ces mots magiques qui
contient à la fois le oui le nom la joie
la crainte face espèce de foisonnement
de vocabulaire pour le partage is it
c'est une merveille la bourse qui se
dore est aussi un trésor en elle-même
quant à la montre tout ça montre bien à
10000 livres n'est ce pas monsieur louis
up auprès madame la comtesse
vous ne mettriez à nu je trouve qu'on
devrait essayer de commencer sa
vieillesse codou de la poursuivre comme
mon doigt cet ep d'adolescence sont tus
vaudrait il faudrait sortir avec
ingénuité
alors c'est comme le théâtre m'offre ça
un peu à possibilité de vagabonder tant
que je vais pouvoir faire ça que des
gens me font confiance pour ça et bien
je vais essayer de continuer comme ça
gomis gens ici sur la scène du théâtre
de mise dans le chant du départ aux
côtés notamment de jacques weber et
d'hélène l'instant elle interprète sous
la direction de jean-pierre d'infos le
rôle d'une extravagante comtesse elle
est comme d'habitude éblouissante fin de
cette édition dans un instant la météo
complète de florence klein je vous
retrouve à 22h10 pour soir trois très
bons db soirée à tous